all right i'm very excited about the
conversation we're going to be having
today
with julian chandra who is not only one
of the creators of the video sharing
platform odyssey
but also the chief marketing officer our
content
has been on odyssey for a while now even
in the earlier iterations of the
platform
um so i'm glad to have you here julian
thanks thanks dave it's great to be here
so my audience will will immediately
remember the many conversations i've had
with them about
over the years we see different
criticisms about various
social media and video sharing platforms
sometimes it's algorithmic bias that's
at issue sometimes it's censorship
sometimes it's partisan imbalance
sometimes it's
what can versus cannot be
monetized in some cases and so
frequently
i think probably three to four times a
week i get an email about
the new alternative it's going to
destroy that platform it's going to make
this platform obsolete
and some of them are great ideas some of
them work well even
but sometimes they get overrun by a huge
right-wing user base
and content rumble comes to mind [ __ ]
shoot comes to mind
odyssey is a video sharing platform much
of the content
is is not political we've been on there
with our political content at
davidpakman.com
odyssey for some time you did not
tell me if i'm wrong julian this this
did not start out to be a political
platform the idea is a video sharing
platform that is open source and
independent
100 correct so what we're trying to do
with odyssey is reinvigorate the spirit
of independent content creation
i think um what you do observe with a
lot of these platforms that you
referenced
and um many of those others quote
unquote youtube
killers yeah um their
entire business model is kind of
based around the premise of okay let's
go and poach the
d-platformed content creator or
un-cancel the cancelled
so to speak right right or in addition
to that you know
um sometimes in tandem with that it's uh
let's call
just one type of creator that's specific
to a political dichotomy
um oftentimes that ends up being just
conservatives
so you end up with a platform that just
looks like right leaning content
exclusively and that's not very um
welcoming to uh you know a huge
swath of um you know uh
generalist type of creator so i want to
talk about the platform i mean
my experience with it is a content
creator but
most of the people that will watch our
conversation today they would experience
it as as users who might just be
looking for my content and similar
content to it
and looking potentially to support my
content so let's start with the users i
mean what what is the idea of the
the user experience on odyssey
um so we appreciate that people have um
you know 10 plus years of culture just
using youtube they know how it works
it's very
um simple uh we want to recreate that
experience
um with odyssey we don't want to do
something too drastic in terms of ui and
that sort of thing
uh in saying that we want to iterate in
um innovative ways
to kind of bring out our own flavor and
some of our um
technological uh feature sets um
when you're looking at users
specifically though um
you know people in in my age and your
age david were kind of
rooted um you know in our
uh social media ecosys systems so to
speak sure
with odyssey what we're really trying to
do here is create something for the gnz
product that is um future proof for them
um
and essentially um beyond that um
on many platforms people are familiar
with interacting with content as a user
you can like content you can dislike
content uh you can leave a comment
uh some platforms allow you know tipping
or financial support
in uh actual currencies others have like
an on
platform token or reward system
how does the odyssey platform work for
the average user
yeah um great question so we have likes
and dislikes um we call them fire and
slime
uh you can tip creators using our lbc
cryptocurrency token
um for users just watching content as
well they earn
um lbc for creators they earn
lbc per verified view as well um
so in terms of like what users come to
expect of traditional
uh well well-established media platforms
odyssey
offers that as well how can the app so
a viewer can reward a creator with
lbc tips how does the user get those
lbc tokens to begin with
they can get the token from watching
video on the platform
when they create their account we give
them a little bit um
to to go inside their wallet so a wallet
is where
um all the earnings users get
uh and then as far as a creator
if you want to create and build an
audience on odyssey
is the flow similar to on other
platforms where you establish an account
you then establish a channel and then
you're able to
upload or otherwise put your content on
that platform
100 right um the the traditional way of
developing an audience and growing your
channel applies to odyssey
the other thing though i if you don't
mind me segwaying is sure um
you we're kind of friendly to the
creators um in
in many respects in the sense that um we
do not use algorithmic controls to
promote one creator over another this
was going to be my next question this
was going to be my
question because on the one hand if
someone
likes my content if someone finds me on
odyssey and they like my content it's
reasonable to think that if odyssey
suggests to them what's similar to me
that it would help them find content
that they would also like the problem
with this is
it can also create a sort of filter
bubble and echo chamber
so i don't i mean is there is there like
a happy medium that you can find on that
issue
um you know you're absolutely right um
one solution we're working toward this
um addressing this
and and we're not 100 sure if this will
be the solution in which case we will
revise
yeah but let's say i like david pakman's
content and i
watch and i followed his channel on
odyssey
what you can do david is um you can
create
um your own custom categories like let's
say you create a category for news and
you can put all the
news creators that you like into that
category then me as an end user i come
and i see this and i can actually
follow that category itself and even pin
it to my home page
so in essence if i like david and i
trust
his recommendations and so forth um you
can share your own algorithm
with users now absent that
with all of the content that's now on
odyssey what determines
what's on the the so-called front page
so to speak for a new user
uh so it's essentially goes by tags
um so what you see on the front page
under these various categories like
cheese and big heads
etc just what channels have tagged
themselves
as so pop culture you know fashion
cooking etc that's it's just a
randomized
you know display of content in terms of
live streaming
is that something that is in the process
of being built out is it available now
yeah it's it's available now it has been
for the past um three weeks
it's still in beta but we're finding um
you know the service improving daily and
more and more
creators are taking advantage of our
live stream service
we can handle up to 10k concurrent
viewers
so far we're hoping to you know test
with a higher number very soon
so in terms of the sec's inquiry right
now
into uh the odyssey platform and if i
understand correctly it's specifically
the token we've seen the sec taken
interest
years ago um in the sort of modern
cryptocurrency era
what counts as a security were the the
tax implications etc
can you talk a little bit about the sec
case and what it means for odyssey
yeah i think um the first and thing we
need to clarify is that the
sec case it does not impact odyssey as a
platform its users its holdings of
um lbc or their earnings the case
is related to our parent company library
um and essentially the case is um
it's a classification issue so
essentially
they allege um that our cryptocurrency
is a security
um we do not um our opinion is also
shared by
many legal experts in the um uh crypto
community um and this is not a unique
question to your token i mean for people
like me who have been following the
space
and follow you know american financial
law as an example
um this this is this is really a big
issue that has significant it's not a
trivial issue
that ultimately uh particularly with the
adoption of bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies
there's is your belief that at some
point there's going to have to be some
kind of definitive
umbrella ruling as to the handling of
these types of tokens
yeah absolutely because right now the
sec does not give any kind of
adequate guideline to blockchain
companies um
full stop yeah um but
what we're really trying to do um with
you know this whole law students etc is
is work through with the sec to make
sure that
we get things right now and for the
future because
you know um this case has some serious
um implications right for the blockchain
crypto space in the
united states um effectively you know
the industry could be rendered destroyed
over
um if we were to lose the case and it
would apply to
virtually all cryptocurrencies in the
united states how would one
uh get started on odyssey i mean as i
mentioned our
channel is at davidpakman.com
odyssey odysse if you're i mean maybe
tell us both as a user and as a creator
is it just you sign up on the on the web
page
yes so if you're a creator you've got
two options available you can go to the
website odyssey.com that's
um you very kindly spelled it out
odyssey.com
when you sign up there is an option to
sync your entire
youtube library uh which is very helpful
if you're a
creator you don't need to go and
manually upload all of your
videos to a new platform and the other
cool thing about this is whenever you do
upload a new video to youtube it's
automatically going to be
mirrored along with the descriptions for
that video onto odyssey
alternative if you're on iphone you can
get the app from
the app store and just sign up through
there
for users general users it's the same
way you can
either get the app and sign up and watch
content or you can just go to the
website
in terms of moderation um what
is it that is the policy of odyssey in
terms of content because this has been
been a big point of contention
both on the major platforms but also on
some of the new upstart
platforms uh some take the position that
they just allow everything
period and others are saying anything is
allowed
short of something that would be illegal
but then when you say that it becomes
the question of well illegal in what
country different countries have
different frameworks so how do you
approach the moderation
perspective yeah and now um i'll i'll
just pre-face my answer by saying our
current community guidelines are under
revision
but essentially our policies are not
unlike
youtube's in many respects we
we do not allow for copyright content
illegal content child abuse
type content um you know
hate speech of many varieties etc
um i think there is a popular
misconception
um that exists with all these new
alternative platforms that rise up and
that they are free-for-all
uh that is not the case with odyssey in
fact
if we were a free-for-all i don't do i
don't think would last very long to be
is that right
and is that because i mean we saw for
example like parlor ended up having
problems
who's going to host them and amazon web
services said we're not going to host it
but they weren't they weren't so much
legal problems why do you that's
interesting that you've made that
decision
what would it be that prevented you from
lasting too long if you if you were a
free-for-all
it's just like when you are a
free-for-all you end up with
having a platform that's very polarizing
to people
right like um
your product ends up your platform
rather it ends up just appealing to a
niche type of user
so it quickly degrades into something
that
um is not really in alignment with your
original intent
or or purpose that's interesting
so it sounds like it's less about you
think you'd get shut down
but it would it would just limit the
appeal essentially
a hundred percent like we want everybody
to love and use odyssey but if our
platform looks like it's only
um whatever yeah
you know without without you know
calling out any kind of specific
group but if it looks like it's just for
these
you know that's going to be very
polarizing for a lot of people
i think that's a that that's probably
accurate
and interesting that that you uh have
taken that position because not
everybody is uh
taking that position with a lot of these
new platforms you can find
uh the david pakman show on odyssey by
going to davidpakman.com
odyssey that's o-d-y-s-e-e
we've been speaking with julian chandra
who's the chief marketing officer at
odyssey and wals also one of the
platform's creators
uh julian thanks so much to for talking
to us about it today
thanks for having me david appreciate it